[Musique]
non
ce bois une grange dpn qu'est ce qui te
ferait plaisir c'est là qu'est ce que tu
me proposes pour les eaux de smith dans
l'affairé aux deux sens les eaux de
smith mon bois l'américaine mais c'est
vrai ça vas voir tu feras garde ces deux
gars a pendant ce temps là je m'en bat
pas le vini elles sont toutes faites
[Musique]
pour cinq ans la brousse la normale et
brit air kito tu aurais dit mme gdf
parce que j'ai pris trop de poids
pendant la grossesse
t'as vu comment je fais parler aux
femmes moi j'ai un bouton sur la gueule
c'est pas pareil mais moi j'en ai plein
c'est le chocolat
[Musique]
je crois que l'hiver est arrivé
bon pour ceux que ça intéresse je suis
passé voir ma grand mère qui en est en
convalescence je me dépêche de partir
parce que là vu la neige qui tombe je
vais être bloqué ça serait con passé la
nuit ici c'est pas que c'est pas mignon
comme établissement mais avec des
personnages et à l'ego au le temps de
ouf s'est mis à neiger d'un coup c'est
blanche et blanc elle seule entre place
et blanc blanc que blanc
on est un petit peu en altitude et si je
fais pas gaffe et pas je vais pas
redescendre sur tout le problème là
c'est moi j'ai une bagnole si tu veux
les pneus neige je ne connais pas si tu
es croyant tu peux voir des prières pour
moi on sait jamais bon qu'est ce que la
voie la vache
[ __ ] c'est tombé en cinq minutes
pourtant justin m'avait dit ne me ne
vient pas ne vient pas by avant que la
neige ne vient pas et ben ouais bah moi
je suis venu voilà ça m'apprendra bon
bah on s'en va tout à l'heure il faut
que l'on bat on va voir un allez croiser
les doigts pour moi pour toi ça va durer
une seconde le temps que je fasse le
montage mais pour moi on est pour 20
minutes le meilleur trois-quarts d'heure
peut-être une deux heures il ya trop de
neige à les dernières vues sur la neige
et à ciao bye bye vive le vent vive le
vent vive le vent d'hiver
un jour de grand mère
ouais
[Musique]
le brésilien à chauffage à fond chez lui
la fenêtre il est temps que tu veux quoi
la grille 10 packs wii burgers frites
boissons moi je veux prendre 231
discount avec le dessert amérique
dessert de gros ces coiffes les muffins
on partage les voitures
comment tu es là pour payer à messi
mérite
monsieur brom est vrai
et c'est moi qui te l'invité de trop
chaud et mais le kiné mi course mais
aussi ça c'est les blogueurs secours de
gastro non mais ça incroyable force et
acheter des fringues but au jeu très
bien habillé comme on dit par ailleurs
ils font du quad buggy burgers halal
michigan faucher les gants
jean carence est là
crèveront comme les autres questions qui
évoque le film vous êtes un magnifique
sa famille vende détester ce ton du
pouvoir maintenant
bios et aymeric caron le chef de file
des jeux gros mais il a pas l'air en
forme maintenant il a débauché french
oui je sais pas s'il a plus de vos
cheveux de tes cheveux sont plus vos
questions moustache gpat les danois en
hongrie sa maille
vous croyez qu'il a comme elle performe
sous ma vie
[Musique]
bonjour je suis un sapin de noël on est
en train de me démonter sauf que là
c'est la pause dej tout le monde s'est
barré donc il ya plus de barrières de
sécurité tout le monde s'en fout s'il y
en a un qui veut servir et prendre sens
atteint il peut se prendre sans
symptômes
[Musique]
[ __ ] ça pique ce matin
à l'adolescence j'ai l'impression
d'avoir 14 ans aujourd'hui il fait super
beau
pas de neige à l'horizon si l'on dit
n'importe quoi la météo
regarde regarde regarde voilà tu vois tu
vois pas tu vois le ciel
je vais arrêter de regarder la météo -
dit n'importe quoi bon me lasser le
matin j'ai pas envie mais pas envie du
tout par contre regarde j'ai mis mon
plus beau t-shirt pour dormir tu vas
kiffer andré rieu your way sexy [ __ ]
encore 5 minutes
c'est pas comme si on était à la fin de
la vidéo